[Music]  imagine what it takes to the legend  someone to the left of the control  feeling of arousal the decision to  humiliate or court how could you  possibly get that from an ordinary  police report  I can choke down the bio manufacturer  empathy when our subjects are at least  informative we decided no one who's been  affected Kemp I'm trying to ward you  your attitude is going to bite you in  the ass you're developing a pattern of  behavior that will not sustain your ear  so Young's really in people's lives we  need to know exactly how worried we need  to blow full rage and needing you  feeling sorry not our job to commiserate  with these people it is our job to  electrocute them can't like everything  we do we're talking to Siri okay if any  of this is little work we need to talk  some more some more you want trouble  you've got to get in the dirt with the  pig no we don't we are the FBI  how do we get ahead of crazy if we don't  know how crazy thinks  you